[Musique]
ce jeudi 9 mars le président du
Département Cyril malkior s'est rendu à
L'Étang-Salé pour visiter les projets de
la commune financés par la collectivité
dans le cadre du pacte de solidarité
territoriale deuxième génération un
déplacement débuté par un accueil du
maire Mathieu Waro à l'hôtel de ville où
ont été présentés les différentes
actions réalisées sur le territoire
amélioration du confort thermique
acoustique et énergétique des écoles de
la commune travaux routier ou encore
installation de toilettes publiques se
déplacement a été marqué par la
signature d'un avenant à la convention
initiale du PST2 d'un montant de 570 000
euros cette avenant servira au
financement de l'aménagement de la
mairie sociale un équipement de
proximité qui permettra aux usagers
d'avoir un accès physique unique dans
leur démarche avec ce soutien financier
supplémentaire se sont près de 3,5
millions d'euros qui sont alloués à la
commune l'étang salé toutes les communes
bénéficient du soutien du Département et
les temps à l'époque de beaux projets
des projets innovants tournés vers la
jeunesse vers l'installation des jeunes
en difficulté doit né aussi vers des
arts de proximité sportifs éducatif et
donc c'est pour cela que je suis là pour
dire oui à Monsieur le Maire de temps ça
allait le département est à vos côtés de
même que sur le golf de L'Étang-Salé ou
un hôtel va sortir de terre un gros
investissement porté par des promoteurs
privés sur des terrains du département
donc tout cela démontre d'une volonté
d'aller de l'avant à L'Étang-Salé et le
maire qui je l'ai dit va faire
remarquable travail mérite notre soutien
le soutien du Département c'est pour
cela que je suis ici aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup de projets et on n'avance pas
seul on a besoin de soutien et de
soutien département est primordial sur
des projets qu'on veut lancer nous on a
de beaux projets pour recréer une vraie
passerelle vers l'économie réelle et
aujourd'hui la problématique du chômage
qui est en train d'impacter la ville ou
même la Réunion mon dos anticiper au
travers de grands projets comme il
disait tout à l'heure le golf de
L'Étang-Salé grâce à son hôtel
aujourd'hui c'est une valeur ajoutée au
golf donc ces créations d'emplois
supplémentaires sur cette détente salée
en plus de ce que nous on est en train
de faire au niveau de notre zone
industrielle nos activités économiques
et commerciales aujourd'hui tous ces
projets au-delà de l'engagement
financier il doit avoir un engagement
politique et aussi un engagement de
personnes cette rencontre en mairie a
été suivie de visites de terrain en
compagnie du maire et de plusieurs élus
d'abord le président du Département
s'est rendu chez Monsieur et Madame
Payet bénéficiaire de l'aide à
l'amélioration de l'habitat l'occasion
de s'assurer du suivi des travaux et de
la satisfaction des usagers
la matinée s'est poursuivie au centre de
secours de la ville qui changera bientôt
de visage puisqu’un projet de
construction d'une nouvelle caserne sera
sur les rails dès janvier 2024 avec une
contribution financière de la part de la
collectivité à hauteur de 80%. ensuite
direction la forêt domaniale de
L'Étang-Salé ou un chantier d'insertion
porté par le CCAS perpétue le
savoir-faire traditionnel du tressage
ici les 5 agents travaillent aussi sur
un jardin partagé dans les récoltes
permettent d'abonder les colis
alimentaires du CCAS
enfin ce déplacement c'est conclu par la
visite d'un des projets structurants du
département sur le territoire le
chantier du Golfe de L'Étang-Salé le
projet de développement porté par Cyrano
et GTOI se décline en trois phases le
réaménagement du complexe la
construction d'un hôtel 4 étoiles et
l'extension du parcours de golf
[Musique]